hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others and I see all kinds
of questions here of different types
let's see I notice one here from Katie
uh why is it important that the periodic
table is structured as a table rather
than a list of elements well let's talk
about what the periodic table is
it's essentially a list of all the kinds
of atoms that can occur in nature
so atoms have a nucleus that contains
protons and neutrons and then outside
the nucleus far away from the nucleus
actually are electrons and the chemical
properties of materials are all
concerned with the way that the
electrons interact with each other the
nucleus is sits there as a tiny little
thing it's like if you have a hydrogen
atom for example which has just one
proton usually at the center and an
electron kind of sort of In This Cloud
around it the the size of the whole
hydrogen atom is a hundred thousand
times larger than the size of the proton
in the middle
so it's uh
most but the question of how atoms kind
of behave is determined as far as
chemistry is concerned is determined by
the way that the electrons from
different atoms interact with each other
when you when you push two atoms close
to each other there might be the
electrons but of those two atoms
interact in various ways because they're
kind of the outer part of the atom and
they're what kind of gets to bump into
other atoms
well
the the big thing that determines how
atoms behave is how many electrons they
have do they have just one electron two
up to um in the case of the the elements
that um are reasonably stable up to 92
electrons
well the um uh the thing that um uh
determines when you have just an atom
sitting there on its own an atom of some
particular chemical element what that
that the the the
nucleus of the atom will have a certain
number of protons so the number of
neutrons also the protons have an
electric charge of plus one unit
electrons always have an electric charge
of minus one unit so in an ordinary
neutral atom just isolated separated
from everything else you'll have an
equal number of protons and electrons so
for example for hydrogen it's got one
proton in the center and that means it
has uh one electron normally
and uh helium has two protons in the
center so two electrons normally and so
then the question is what so what
determines the properties of atoms in
terms of their chemical interactions
that is atoms just sort of
sitting next to each other with their
electron clouds kind of touching that's
determined by the number of electrons in
the atom and uh
the whole story of chemistry is is the
story of how different kind of clouds of
electrons from different atoms interact
with each other whether it's um uh in
making water H2O for example
um that uh uh has an oxygen atom and
that has a couple of hydrogen atoms and
the kind of electrons of the hydrogen
atoms interact with the electrons and
the oxygen atom okay so there's a a very
typical uh question which is sort of how
roughly are the electrons arranged
around the atom
and electrons get arranged in what are
called shells and it's a little bit
there's a bit of sort of conflict
between the very abstract way of talking
about it that's kind of more kind of
scientifically correct and the way of
talking about it that's easier to
understand and that works just fine for
most of the kind of reasoning you have
to do in thinking about how chemistry
works
but let me talk about the kind of more
scientifically correct version of it
first
the first thing to understand is that an
electron is well in traditional physics
people have thought that electrons are
just perfect geometrical points of zero
size protons are not protons everybody
knows well people know that a proton is
a thousandth trillionth of a meter
across 10 to the minus 15 meters across
that's the size of a proton it's got
quarks and all kinds of other stuff
inside it it's got a definite
substructure but electrons so far as
people have been able to tell electrons
are just points with nothing inside them
and what we know right now is electrons
and certainly smaller than 10 to the
minus 21 meters across
well
in The Theory of physics that I've been
involved in developing the last few
years
electrons are no longer thought of as as
precise geometrical points they actually
have a substructure but their
substructure might be at 10 to the minus
1 10 to the minus 90 meters or something
as Tiny as that so really really tiny
compared to everything else we're
dealing with so electrons as individual
things are they're like Point objects
but
when it's very hard to pin down
electrons very hard to know oh the
electron is right here and it isn't
somewhere else and this is kind of
partly the story of quantum mechanics
that quantum mechanics kind of says you
don't actually know precisely where
things are or what things are doing you
just have a whole collection of
possibilities and only when you kind of
observe it only when you choose to make
a measurement are you actually sort of
in some sense nailing down well this is
the definite place where it showed up
right now so what happens in an atom is
that there are electrons and each
individual electron is like really
really tiny but knowing where each
electron is you don't really know so you
kind of think of the electron as being
in this kind of cloud of electronness
and if you really poked it in the right
way you could say well right now when I
poked it the electron is right here and
it's not quite a question of oh right
now it's here and that and then it will
be somewhere else later it's really a
One-Shot thing and that comes up in our
Theory of physics because in fact the
the whole universe is branching into
multiple different histories one history
in which the electronics in this place
one history it's in which it's in that
place and when you kind of think to
measure it your mind is effectively
picking a particular history more or
less and so that's kind of how it works
it's not like it it was first there then
it's there it's like it's in all those
places but when we choose to measure it
when we decide this is the this is a
measurement our our mind is kind of
homing in on one of those possible
branches but any case so in the usual
kind of Theory of physics that's existed
for about the last hundred years there's
this notion of a so-called electron wave
function the electron wave function is
essentially giving you the the more or
less the probability that an electron is
at a particular position in for example
an atom so relative to the hydrogen and
hydrogen atom there's a nucleus at the
center maybe it has a single proton in
it that's the most common case then
there is a electron wave function
there's an electron essentially
probability distribution I'm hedging a
little bit because the probability
distribution is actually the square of
the wave function and there's a bunch of
fancy stuff about the individual
so-called Quantum amplitude but let's
ignore that for now it's not really
relevant for what we're talking about
right now then the question is well
where does the electron typically hang
out where's where's the highest chance
that it hangs out well it hangs out in a
hydrogen atom at a distance that's
called the bore radius on average it's
about
um a a um uh 1 10 billionth of a meter
10 to the minus 10 meters and that and
so what if you look at the chance that
you find electron somewhere it the
chance goes It goes right close to the
nucleus it's not very high goes up it's
around 10 minus 10 meters away from the
nucleus it's the largest value and then
it drops off it actually drops off
exponentially as you go further out
um and so in a in a hydrogen atom in its
most normal State that's just that
electron is it's got one electron it's
just kind of hanging out and the chances
are we found roughly one more radius
away from the the the hydrogen uh
nucleus
it doesn't it's not that's so what
happens in quantum mechanics is that
there are different possible states of a
hydrogen atom so the the state that has
the lowest energy is the one I just
described where the electron is on
average the Spore radius away from from
the from the nucleus
well the the hydrogen atom has a
collection of discrete energy levels and
you can think of them a little bit like
the electron has this constraint that at
Infinity if you go far enough away from
the from the from the nucleus the chance
that you find
um an electron is is essentially zero
and it'll sort of also has a constraint
that it it uh well doesn't quite have
the constraint that it can't be at the
nucleus but it it has it has a
constraint that you're kind of getting
into the center and there's there's no
there's no there's no volume at zero
radius there's sort of no volume in
which it can exist
um it's only as you go further out that
there could be there's sort of space for
the electron to be there so there's
constraints on the electron wave
function those constraints are somewhat
similar to the constraints you might
have if you have a string for example
and you've attached the two ends and you
pluck the string you can you can pluck
the string in such a way that the string
bows out out just once in such a way
that the string bows out twice bows out
three times it always has to bow out a
whole number of times but you can get
different bowings out depending on how
you how you sort of uh how you excite
the string same kind of thing for
electrons and hydrogen atoms the uh what
happens is there are these different uh
what are called eigenstates of the
hydrogen atom where you get these
different Arrangements of electron wave
function and you'll you'll get ones
where the electron is is always right in
in this in a particular
configuration ones where it's in a
different configuration and so on and
they're a discrete set of these they're
discrete collection of those uh
different possible States
um the the equation when in in the
mathematics of these things the um
uh when you look at the equations that
are satisfied by this sort of position
on a string that's the thing called the
wave equation by the electron wave
functions is it's a thing called the
Schrodinger equation invented by a chap
called Owen schoner in about 1920 around
1920.
um the uh in any case what happens is
there are these discrete possible states
of the hydrogen atom and the way that
they are
characterized well let's see just like a
um
roughly okay and this is um you know the
mathematics is very well defined for
this the intuitive explanation is a
little bit fuzzier
but
um one can sort of describe the
different possible modes of the hydrogen
atom the lowest energy one then the one
that's slightly higher energy where the
electron is kind of uh running around a
bit more quickly in some sense and so on
and and very roughly the those different
states are characterized by roughly
how
much
whether whether the electron is just
sort of on average at any at any
orientation relative to the nucleus so
the lowest energy configuration is
so-called spherically symmetric it has
the the probability that the electron is
any in any particular position relative
it's like if you had the had the the
Earth for example uh as as if you have
the surface of the Earth and you were
thinking that the center of the hydrogen
atom and the center of the earth you
could say what's the chance that you
find the electron at a certain longitude
and latitude well in the lowest energy
state it has an equal chance to be found
at any longitude and latitude as you go
to the next
State the electron is kind of roughly
like it's kind of running around more
quickly and it's running around in a
definite orientation so it's either sort
of running around the equator of the
Earth or it's running around North Pole
to South Pole and so on and that is the
fancy quantum mechanics version of that
is it has what's called orbital angular
momentum and um the uh uh you can
roughly think about it as kind of
spinning around one way or another way
because of the story of quantum
mechanics and the story of the fact that
you only have these discrete possible
configurations it basically has
um in the case of sort of running okay
when it's in the lowest energy states
it's sort of not running around at all
the next energy state is kind of running
around in in one way and then the one
after that it's kind of running around
sort of in in twice as many possible
ways and so on okay the end result of
all of this is that in the case where
it's sort of running around
uh in in a in one way it turns out there
are sort of three possible distinct
states of the hydrogen atom that more or
less correspond to the three different
orientations of uh the of the way that
the electron is kind of orbiting around
it's a very rough approximation the
mathematics is a little different from
that but that's sort of a rough
intuitive explanation so there's the
sort of lowest energy State and um the
uh um
uh the the lowest energy State it's kind
of all directions are equivalent the
next energy State there's kind of one
preferred Direction and it can go kind
of uh in any of the three uh sort of
coordinate directions in three
dimensions okay then you get to the next
state and it has uh five possible uh um
that there are five possible
configurations so to speak the next one
there are seven and so on it goes up by
odd numbers uh now you might be trying
to ask me to get a give an intuitive
explanation
oh let's see uh the mathematics is not
well I can say the words of what's
actually going on these are uh
well different ways to say it I mean
they're the representations of the
rotation group they are different
um
let's not go down that path I can
explain that to people who are
interested I can explain why it goes up
by odd numbers and so on but the basic
bottom line is
um there are the number of possible
configurations of an electron with
lowest energy one with its next higher
energy is three next one is five next
one is seven
okay
so uh
that's how that works those are
um okay the next important fact is the
thing called the Exclusion Principle
which says that if you're putting more
electrons If instead of one looking at a
hydrogen atom one looks at a carbon atom
for example with six protons in its
nucleus and six electrons
um that would sort of naturally be in um
uh in its uh around it did I get that
right let's say it's hydrogen helium
lithium beryllium boron carbon yes
carbon is six
nitrogen oxygen fluorine neon Etc
um the uh
so in the case of a carbon atom there
are six electrons that you have to kind
of put into these different possible
States so there'll be electrons that are
in that lowest energy State and then you
can put electrons into other states okay
important fact about electrons they
don't like each other in the following
sense
once you have
one electron and a particular energy
State no other electron is prepared to
go into that same energy State actually
it's a little bit trickier than that
because an electron has two different
so-called spin States roughly the
electron can be oriented so that it is
sort of spinning on its axis in some
sense except it doesn't really have an
axis and doesn't really spin but it has
a thing that's called spin
um it has a property that's called spin
and it can either be sort of in the up
direction or the down Direction there
are two possibilities so when I say
there's that no two electrons could be
in the same state actually if you
account for the fact that the electrons
can be either in their sort of spin up
or spin down configuration it means two
electrons can go into a single one of
these energy levels that I described so
lowest energy thing the spherically
symmetric one there can be at most two
electrons that go in there and that one
can that is sort of the lowest electron
L is the the electrons that will sort of
go into that lowest energy configuration
okay you put another electron in where's
it going to go well it's going to go to
the next kind of energy level which is
this thing that I describe it has three
possibilities that is kind of the
electron with a certain with essentially
one unit of orbital angular momentum and
so for that shell there are am I getting
this right that shell there should be
um
uh the
that there should be uh
six possibilities yes I think that's
right
um and then
the next one up that has five possible
configurations okay there are there are
two possibilities for each electron so
there's ten possible configurations of
that and so on so as you keep trying to
have atoms with more and more electrons
those electrons are sort of going into
these higher and higher shells
um they are going into energy states
that correspond to
um sort of uh that they go into this
sort of higher energy states that are
progressively a little bit further away
from the nucleus and have these other
characteristics okay so what is the
periodic table well
the periodic table not that Mendeleev
knew this one he made it he just made it
based on sort of the properties of
chemicals and so on but what It
ultimately is is it's something where
you're lining up cases where the number
of empty slots
in the outer shell of the atom is the
same in a particular column
and why is that important well because
in the chemistry of atoms what matters
is these atoms kind of bumping into each
other and trying to form so-called bonds
bonds the most common kind of bonds
so-called covalent bonds come about
because essentially electrons in these
two atoms are kind of getting exchanged
with each other and that happens because
there's there's kind of a uh there's a
there's a kind of a um
in this outer shell kind of electron
from the other atom could go if there's
a hole in that outer shell if it isn't
quite full then an electron from the
other atom can kind of like spend a
little bit of its time if those atoms
are right next to each other can spend a
little bit of its time in the position
of that the the place where it would be
for the other atom but if the shell is
filled then there sort of isn't a place
for another electron to get in and kind
of have the the the the that other atom
sort of pockets electron into the
electron cloud of the other atom so when
you have a closed shell it's kind of
very hard to have a chemical reaction
with something that has a closed
electron shell and the in other words
when when when all the slots are filled
the only way that you can sort of add an
electron to that atom is to go to the
next Shell which requires you to have a
higher energy electron and so on so that
means that atoms that have uh closed
shells tend to be pretty non-reactive
and if you look in a periodic table on
the right hand side of the periodic
table are the noble gases which are
helium uh
Neon
Krypton Xenon am I missing one
uh those I think there's a I miss the
one I may be missing one but any case
those those atoms correspond to the
filled shells to cases where the number
of electrons is enough to fill a shell
and those atoms are not reactive because
another atom when it comes near it can't
poke one of its electrons into the into
a sort of an empty space in the electron
shell
so in general there's this notion of
valence and Valence is kind of the the
number of holes
um oh I thank you somebody pointed at
argon I forgot argon my apologies
um
uh
the um so uh
in any case the the um
uh this question of sort of how many how
many holes are there in the outer
electron shell is what determines kind
of how much poking there can be from
another atom
and and roughly that that ends up
determining the so-called valence of the
um
let's see I think that the way to think
about this probably is maybe the other
way around of kind of how many how many
electrons are there kind of hanging out
in that outer shell that where there's
still holes left in the outer shell but
okay so hydrogen has valence one uh
carbon has valence four for example
Etc and that determines that that's sort
of basic chemistry determining kind of
what chemical compounds are easy to make
you can have kind of carbon and it can
have four hydrogens sort of being nearby
because the electrons from those four
hydrogen atoms are kind of sticking
themselves into the the kind of holes in
the outer electron shell of the carbon
does it actually work out that way let
me just think about that for a second
I'm not sure I've ever worked it out
quite like this uh so let's see carbon
has six electrons and so it has uh of
those six electrons two are in the inner
shell so then it has it should have uh
four electrons in the next
um
level out and there should be in there
are three
hmm that doesn't quite work out
something uh something is slightly off
here I I need to I need to um uh I'm
giving you at least a a qualitative
explanation of what's going on I think
my either my arithmetic or something was
off a bit here
um but any case the um
so the point of the periodic table is
it's kind of this map of how many uh
sort of how
how many spaces there are and how many
extra electrons there are in this kind
of outer electron shell
um at for each kind of atom and that
determines kind of how those atoms will
interact with other atoms because it's
the outside of the electron of this sort
of electron cloud that bumps up against
other atoms and is important for
chemistry
um and so the the arrangement of the
periodic table is all about that and the
reason you know you see the thing has
has sort of a small number of on the
successive rows correspond to the
filling of successful electron shells
and so at the very top you've got kind
of hydrogen helium that's the very first
electron shell and there's just two
elements there then you get to the next
electron shell and you should have uh uh
more elements across and I'm not
visualizing my table very well
um and that's the next electron shell
and you keep going down and of course
when you as as the number of electrons
that fit in the electron shells go up it
means you you have to have more and more
and more things across the periodic
table to represent all the different
possible uh numbers of things that can
be missing in these electron shells
um and uh the and so that's why this
sort of this extra pull out of the um
the lanthanide series and the actinide
series are kind of these things from a
from one of the larger electron shells
that has more slots in it and you're
kind of representing all the different
configurations there now there are some
more details because there are
oh there are subshells as well
um that are important for the way that
these these atoms can interact
so one thing
um the
uh one one comment about this is you
might ask well you know these atoms with
all these electrons and all these
complicated electron configurations how
do you work out how these all work the
answer is it's really hard
for the hydrogen atom it was figured out
100 years ago how the electron the
probability distribution for an electron
and hydrogen atom by the time you get up
further down the periodic table where
you've got you know let's say 50
electrons in in the atom it's really
difficult to figure out what the
probabilities are for the positions of
all of those electrons
um and it's been a a major kind of
challenge of of computational chemistry
and so on to be able to work all that
stuff out it's it's still really hard to
do and the uh the thing that and the
reason it's hard to do is if it was just
asking where is a single electron going
to be in sort of the excited states of a
hydrogen atom that's that's easy the
difficulty is when there are many
electrons that are all interacting with
each other they all have electric charge
not only they have electric charge they
also have Exclusion Principle idea that
prevents the two electrons from sort of
ever being in the same state together
taking accounts of all those things
makes it a really difficult
computational problem and uh it's been
it's been really hard to work out the
the full kind of details of um of all of
these different electron configurations
and uh it's it's sort of a something of
a of a black art to figure out if you
have for example one would like to be
able to ask I got a bunch of atoms are
they going to all you know bind together
to make a chemical compound and what
chemical compound will they make how
will the atoms be arranged in the
chemical compound
that question is answerable for small
numbers of atoms but by the time you're
above 100 or so atoms becomes really
hard to answer in a precise way
um it's answerable when you make certain
approximations for example if you just
say like in your average kind of um uh
sort of theoretical chemistry kit you'll
just have a bunch of balls with a bunch
of sticks that correspond to the
essentially valence electrons
um that can be sort of exchanged with
other atoms if if you in that kind of
model you can say oh yeah you've got
this thing where you can arrange it's
kind of um you know there's a carbon and
there's two oxygens or something and it
it you know that makes carbon dioxide
um and that's all good or you can make
oxygen and it has you know two bonds
between two oxygen atoms it makes O2 the
standard version of oxygen but then
there are all kinds of exceptions like
well how exactly does ozone O3 work how
does some how does some
oh I don't know Xenon hexafluoride it's
a compound of xenon Xenon is a is a
noble gas which supposedly doesn't make
compounds because it just has this
closed shell and so on there are all
kinds of weird exceptions those weird
exceptions that don't work according to
the standard kind of high school
chemistry rules Come about because the
actual story of where the electrons are
going is considerably more complicated
than just this counting of valences and
things like this and that's the thing
that is difficult to work out
computationally and still challenging
and if you ask the question you know can
there be a compound I don't know can
there be a gold compound I don't think
they're only known
um but maybe there are but Xenon for
example one might not have known that it
was possible to make a compound to make
a a molecule where where something had
stuck onto this the Xenon thing but it
is
um
so let's see uh
well that was a um
uh
a bit of a long story about periodic
table and people you know the real point
of the periodic table is that things in
a given column sort of behave in some
chemically similar way because they have
a similar number of kind of uh valence
electrons hanging around or similar
um and that's that's that's the main
story of the organization of it and you
know you can ask questions like okay are
there things like periodic tables for
other types of things like for example
what about Atomic nuclei so we talked
about what happens when you have
electrons when you have chemistry
chemistry is about whole atoms with
their electrons bumping into the
electrons of other atoms but in nuclear
physics one's consumer nuclei and for
example one might be concerned with what
happens when two nuclei bump into each
other most of the time nuclei are kept
far apart by the electron clouds in in
atoms and so on when you're you know if
you want to have nuclear fusion for
example the whole thing that's happening
for example what powers the Sun and so
on is that nuclei can get crushed
together
um and and then fuse and so you can ask
questions like well are there analogs of
the periodic table for for nuclei where
you can say that the properties of
nuclei would be the same particular
nuclei would be the same as other ones a
nuclei
and and atoms the most important thing
is how many electrons are there for
nuclei there are two important things
how many protons are in the nucleus and
how many neutrons are in the nucleus and
roughly there are a bit more neutrons
than a nucleus than there are protons
particularly when you get to to heavier
elements kind of like the protons
they're all stuck together I think I've
talked about this another time by the
strong nuclear force
um and they're all pushed apart by
electrical forces electrical repulsion
but the neutrons kind of uh are hanging
out along with the protons and and I
think they're usually maybe one-third
more neutrons than there are protons in
in sort of the heavier elements in their
most stable form different isotopes
correspond to different numbers of
neutrons with a fixed number of protons
the number of protons determines which
element one's talking about the number
of neutrons determine which isotope of
the element one's talking about but you
can ask questions about just like we
talked about the way that electrons are
arranged in in atoms we cannot talk
about how are the protons and neutrons
arranged in a new nucleus and again
there's a complicated story of shells
and there's this idea of when when you
get certain nuclei uh
have so-called magic numbers and those
correspond to cases in which the the
nucleons the neutrons and protons can be
arranged in these sort of closed shell
type configurations and those nuclei
have special properties they have um uh
well they they're sort of spherical
symmetric they're sort of known to be
spherical symmetric there are other
nuclei which can be kind of elongated
and which effectively are spinning
around
um as a result of that and that leads to
all sorts of different properties and
you can make sort of a periodic table
like thing for nuclei which determines
their properties based on very much the
same kind of shell counting type of type
of approach
okay
um
ah well
uh rudo is asking
is periodic table just the table for the
current state
um talking about the big bang and other
things all right let's talk briefly
about that
so there are well give or take
there are about 92 stable elements
actually a little bit less than that so
remember the elements going hydrogen
helium lithium beryllium Boron Etc
progressively more protons
for each element there may be many
different isotopes many different
numbers of neutrons that can exist in
the nucleus
but if you have too many neutrons or too
few neutrons the nucleus will be
unstable it'll fall apart in some way if
you have too many neutrons the neutrons
tend to Decay on their own if you have
too many protons you'll tend to have
sort of the inverse of that reaction
um and so for example in the in the case
of hydrogen There's A protein that the
the the isotope of hydrogen with just a
single proton there's deuterium which is
the isotope of hydrogen with a proton
and a neutron then this tritium a proton
and two neutrons tritium is unstable
with a half-life of I don't know 17
years or something on average on average
there'll be a half of all tritium atoms
if you tritium nuclei if you have them
will have decayed away and turned into
uh I think the decays to deuterium and
electrons
um uh yeah the the um
um
no no it decays what was it okay to
let's see electron
I'm not sure okay in any case it decays
what one of the neutrons uh turns into a
proton an electron and an anti-neutrino
but that leaves it with two protons and
a neutron and that's not stable so I
don't know quite what happens next
um the uh yes it is I'm sorry that is
it's helium-3 that's that's correct
that's what it decays to
um
and uh
in any case the thing that um
uh
when you put in more you know to to have
a given number of protons a given
element there's the question of are
there a number of neutrons that you can
put in so that you will get a stable
isotope of that element
and for the first 42 elements there's
always at least one stable isotope
there's always at least one number of
neutrons so that the nucleus won't fall
apart sometimes there are several
sometimes there will be 10 or more
um but there's always at least one until
you get to element 43 technetium
technetium is the first element where
there just isn't any stable isotope
there's no way to get a nucleus with
with uh 43 protons and any number of
neutrons that doesn't unstable and Decay
radioactively so 43 there's a hole in
the periodic table for an unstable
element there's another one at 60
promethium and then the next uh and and
that's kind of a weird thing that there
are these uh sort of low-lying elements
that have fairly small numbers of
protons that are unstable well then you
keep going a long way and you get up to
uranium which is the next one 92 which
is also unstable although uh it's it has
isotopes that are stable for billions of
years so it is unstable but not very
unstable and then everything beyond that
so far as we know is unstable now
nobody's ever proved that there's no
heavier elements that could be stable
people believe nowadays that there
aren't any stable heavier elements but
nobody has proved that there isn't an
element with 200 protons for example and
some and 600 neutrons or something that
suddenly will become stable it's not
knowing that that's not the cases
believe that that's not the case and
there's pretty good evidence that that
isn't the case because one's looked up
to elements with 120 125 protons and
things and those elements get
progressively more and more unstable but
it always used to be believed 50 years
ago it was believed that there might be
an island with stability a place where
you would again get stable uh stable
nuclei hasn't hasn't been found probably
doesn't exist
so that means that that the elements as
you go to larger numbers of protons
you're always just getting things that
are very unstable so the question then
is well where do those come from well
the answer is you have to make them by
colliding together other pieces of other
nuclei and so on to get sort of the the
extra protons to stick onto a nucleus
for at least a little while until the
thing blows up and and decays again but
the elements that we have uh so all the
elements that we have are ultimately
made
um in the in the previous history of the
universe
in the Big Bang at the beginning of the
universe the uh well what what happened
was the universe was originally
extremely hot where none of these things
like nuclei and even protons just there
was so much energy so much sort of heat
that any one of those kinds of objects
would just gets would get
you know smashed apart and so all that
there was at the very very beginning of
the universe was whatever the most
Elementary possible particles are
actually in our model of physics it's a
little bit more elaborate than that the
beginning of the universe not only were
kind of all the particles broken up but
so was space and in fact space instead
of behaving as three-dimensionally as it
does now in our models of physics space
um uh behave had um uh uh space was
infinite dimensional we think and space
itself was very kind of bubbling around
and and not stable in any way as it sort
of cooled down these little sort of
lumps of features of space that turn
into particles could be identified and
then it kind of went on from there and
so before
about
um uh one microsecond after the
beginning of the universe millionth of a
second after the beginning of the
universe
there was probably at most you would be
able to identify some electrons some
quarks and they're all sort of bouncing
around
then as the universe sort of got a
little bit colder the corks would kind
of con you know uh form into
um
uh into protons for example electrons
are still bubbling around on their own
um
at about one second after the beginning
of the universe was the possibility of
nuclei forming that was that that was
the time at which the temperature of the
universe was low enough that if a if
some some uh protons and neutrons stuck
together they wouldn't be blown apart by
heat
associated with the with the the sort of
the heat of the of the universe so to
speak the next big event in the history
of the universe is at a hundred thousand
years after the beginning of the
universe which is what's called
recombination which is where the the
amount of heat has gone down the
temperature has gone down to the point
where uh the electrons and protons can
form ordinary atoms where it isn't the
case that the things are bat being
bashed around so much that an electron
can't sort of attach itself around a
proton to make hydrogen for example and
that instead instead before that before
100 000 years after the beginning of the
universe it would always sort of the
electrons and protons would always be
you know bashed around to the point
where they couldn't form neutral atoms
that point a hundred thousand years
after the beginning of the universe is
an important point it's the time of
so-called recombination shouldn't really
be called recombination because these
things were combining for the first time
in the history of our universe but it
means combining the protons and
electrons into into neutral hydrogen
atoms and the reason that's important is
because before that time the universe
was not transparent to light it's more
like it was it was like a plasma like
fire where you kind of can't see through
it but a hundred thousand years after
the beginning of the universe it started
the universe started to be transparent
and that means that any light that was
produced at that time can just travel
through the universe since that time
without unless it hits something can
just travel without uh without being
stopped and that's important because the
cosmic microwave background is that
light in any direction in the sky there
is a small there's a at a very it's
effectively a low temperature because of
the expansion of the universe there is
uh one is C in this sort of primeval
Fireball this this original uh the the
original kind of photons that were
produced before the universe became
transparent so it's kind of the the
place where it became transparent was a
hundred thousand years off the beginning
we get to see those photons okay so in
terms of nuclei
um one second after the beginning of the
universe nuclei I started to form and um
the uh
and the question is which nuclei formed
was it just hydrogen or was there more
well it's a complicated calculation that
was done uh in the 1970s and 1980s
so-called
um Cosmic nucleosynthesis the formation
of of nuclei
um and uh
um it was um uh that was
what happened is
it was a difficult calculation and
actually I I well it was a little bit
involved in some pieces of that
um but uh the um the calculation
um
implied that about it about a quarter of
all nuclei that were made at the very
beginning of the universe were helium
nuclei and the rest for hydrogen nuclei
and there was just a tiny number of
deuterium nuclei so helium nucleus is
two protons two neutrons usually
um the hydrogen nucleus just a single
proton deuterium nucleus a proton a
neutron so there's a whole zoo of
different kinds of um uh of nuclei that
were made in the Big Bang but and their
ratios one can compute based on a
working out kind of the rate of
reactions between different nuclei and
things like this but there was almost
nothing if you go down to lithium or
other heavier elements almost none of
that was made in the Big Bang according
to the calculations one can make about
so the density of of material and so on
and how how often nuclei would run into
each other all those kinds of things
almost nothing Beyond well maybe lithium
was made in the Big Bang so where do the
heavy elements come from well the answer
is that they basically come from uh well
they mostly come from supernovas they
come from exploding Stars Where Stars
got sort of too big they collapsed they
they kind of use up the the pressure
that comes from all the nuclear
reactions but like the sun for example
where there are hydrogen hydrogen Fusion
is occurring that all the hydrogen is
kind of used up and at that point the
the there's no longer as much energy
that can be produced in the star it
doesn't have as much pressure pushing it
out there's this sort of catastrophic
moment when the star will collapse and
it starts at that point it starts um
producing uh lots of much heavier nuclei
confused together and then it produces
the whole spectrum of nuclei going all
the way up to the very unstable ones
Beyond uranium and things like this
um and that's where for example all the
gold that we have on the earth came from
well actually there's there's two
mechanisms but mostly it came from
supernovas one way or another mostly
came from this rapid process of um uh
uh of the of the sort of the the last
few seconds of the collapsing star
causing these nuclear reactions to occur
that produce heavy elements
so uh the at the very early in the very
early Universe even probably the
galaxies that the the web Space
Telescope can see
um the first galaxies that can see
probably don't have much gold for
example in them it's only the the later
populations of stars and galaxies that
have that in them and um the uh so you
know because some Stars uh our son will
live 10 billion years it's been about
it's been around for about five billion
so far
um but there are other stars that live
for only a few million years and produce
supernovas quite rapidly larger stars
for example often do that
um and uh those stars as a Galaxy forms
those they're these kind of areas where
where lots of of of
um uh sort of short-lived Stars exist
they produce supernovas that produces
material that can be then used to form
other stars and that's how the heavy
elements are produced
okay so that's that's on the on the
coming in that's how elements get
produced now on the kind of going out
what will happen sufficiently long in
the future
well one question is is a hydrogen atom
just hanging out is it stable is it just
gonna stay that way forever Let's ignore
the question of whether giant black
holes form like exist at the center of
our galaxy and things like that and just
become essentially vacuum cleaners that
vacuum up all the matter and in the
universe that's a separate issue
let's just talk about a solitary
hydrogen atom so an Interstellar and a
galactic space there's roughly one
hydrogen atom per cubic meter so there's
not a lot there but there's there's
something there but it's just a hydrogen
atom it's just hanging out you know
waiting for the rest of the universe to
occur so to speak one question is does
it get to hang out forever or does it
eventually decay in some way so nobody
knows
and there was a period of time about 40
years ago when people were pretty sure
the proton was unstable
so uh we're pretty sure that a proton
would eventually Decay into a positron
an anti-electron together with uh
neutrino and maybe photons and so on
um and so people did these experiments
looking for proton decay you just have a
big tank of anything you know fluid and
you wait and you see whether uh if you
if you whether whether just all nuclei
eventually self-destruct including
hydrogen nuclei
um and uh well no such thing was found
it's hard to do that experiment because
you have to have it in a deep mine for
example where you're shielding it from
the cosmic rays that hit the earth and
so on and cause uh sort of nuclear
reactions to happen
but um
so people thought that the proton might
have a lifetime around 10 to the 30th
years so
um
let's see a a trillion trillion trillion
uh well roughly that yes that was a
calculation done on the basis of uh uh
so-called Grand unified gauge theories
um that the proton might have a might
have a lifetime of that order wasn't
found it set off a big sort of uh big
soul-searching and maybe panic in
particle physics that it wasn't found
because it seemed like it seemed like
all the sort of theory was aligning that
that should be found but it wasn't so we
don't know if protons are unstable or
not photons could be unstable with a
lifetime of 10 to the 40th years or
something we don't know
um the theory does still hang out there
that yes protons should eventually be
unstable there are several mechanisms
that should lead to that instability but
it might be but it hasn't ever been
observed so we don't know for sure so
then if you ask the question what's the
universe going to be like the biggest
effect of the Universe on very large
times is gravitational probably not the
decaying of the protons if the protons
even do Decay it's much more that the
that the different parts of the universe
into black holes and black holes and
black holes kind of basically time stops
The Singularity of a black hole and you
have you end up with these the situation
where that's that's what it looks like
black hole but it's actually more
complicated yet than that because black
holes as a result of quantum mechanics
eventually evaporate away although if
it's a big black hole it takes an
absurdly long time for that to happen
but eventually they evaporate away and
they kind of in a sense disgorge a
ground up version of their contents they
produce lots of particles so the picture
of what the extremely long time limit of
the universe looks like is a quite
complicated question and it has to do
with exactly what the rate of expansion
of the universe is it has to do with all
of these effects I'm talking about with
black holes it has to do with well a
thing people talks about a lot even 150
years ago was the so-called heat death
of the universe where kind of what's
happened happened is everything is just
a gas and all the molecules are just
bouncing around quotes randomly and all
the interesting stuff in the universe is
over that was a belief about how the
universe would end up that belief is
surely not really right I mean
gravitational effects and black holes
and things kind of uh blow up that that
picture and the second thing that blows
up that picture is yes it is true that
the molecules in a gas bounce around in
a way that for most practical purposes
for us look random but they're not
really random they are determined by the
past history of the gas and so the far
future of our universe which may have a
bunch of molecules bouncing around that
far future is determined by our current
existence in the universe and in that
far future some encoded version of
everything that we are now will exist in
those molecules bouncing around so while
we with our current kind of sensory
apparatus where all we notice is kind of
big chunks of molecules and so on with
our current sensory operators we'll say
oh it's all just random in the Far Far
distant future to an entity with
different sensory operators that for
example can notice where every
individual molecule goes it may be oh no
it's not random at all it's this
elaborate dance of molecules that is a
representation of the future of all of
this fancy stuff those those people back
in you know 2023 or something were doing
uh
all right there's a question here from
proud how we how certain are we that the
Big Bang actually happened
um I think we're pretty certain that the
Big Bang happened
um we're pretty certain
that
uh the universe was very small at the
beginning
we're pretty certain back to the time of
recombination 100 000 years after the
beginning that at that time the universe
was hot and also we know from kind of
seeing if we look in different
directions in the sky we're essentially
seeing different parts it kind of gets
inverted what we see on the sky and what
sort of this this ball was like kind of
inverted but we're basically seeing the
temperature the effective temperature of
different parts of that of that kind of
uh original uh ball of material it's a
little bit difficult to say ball of
material because it's a ball of material
that is the whole universe it's not
expanding into something empty it is the
universe all sort of in that ball but in
any case we can look at the cosmic
microwave background and we can see just
what is the temperature in different
directions and we can see there's about
a thousandth of a degree difference in
in different places uh as of of what the
temperature is it makes a very elaborate
pattern on the sky and
you know what those fluctuations are
like well they're partly explained
they're partly and and those are
explained by features of of uh kind of
what happens in the gravitational
processes in the very early Universe it
could be that hiding in those Wiggles in
the cosmic microwave background is
evidence for something associated with
our recent Theory of physics our recent
Theory of physics talks about the fact
that the dimensionality of the universe
starts infinite dimensional gradually
sort of cools down to three-dimensional
but there will probably be Dimension
fluctuations that get left over where
there are pieces of the universe that
behave as if they're 3.01 dimensional or
something and that will be rather
similar probably to the effect of
gravity in those areas we don't know
exactly what those effects will be it
really has to still be worked out but
possibly hiding in the details of the
cosmic microwave background
um are features fluctuations in the
temperature of the microwave background
that could be a sign of dimensional
fluctuations and could show us that
things about how this theory of ours
Works which will be pretty exciting but
we have a pretty good understanding of
sort of why the cosmic microwave
background is is something you know at a
hundred thousand years we pretty much
seem to have a good understanding of
that now there were some Mysteries
earlier on like for example one of the
things about the universe is that in a
sense we look in One Direction in the
universe we see a bunch of galaxies we
see other things we're looking at the
other direction in the universe we see
something that's kind of comparable to
what we see in the first Direction and
if we look at the cosmic micro
background yeah it might differ by a
thousandth of a degree out of 2.7
degrees 2.7 it's the the effective
temperature now is 2.7 kelvins 2.7
degrees above absolute zero originally
it was 6000 degrees roughly six thousand
bucks
four thousand somewhere in that a few
thousand degrees
um at the time of recombination but the
expansion of the universe has caused the
effective uh temperature
to be much lower now
so the um uh but in any case
you know what we see roughly is that the
effective temperature looking in One
Direction in the universe is about the
same within a thousands of degree let's
say the effective temperature looking in
the other direction
but yet that might seem very mysterious
because how could it be the case that
those looking in photons coming from
those two directions those photons have
never had a chance to interact before
those photons coming from those two
different interactions the first time
they're at the same place is when they
hit our eyes so to speak they they never
interacted before at least that's the
the most obvious picture
and so there's a a um uh there's sort of
this question of how come the universe
knows to be homogeneous uniform given
that it didn't get to interact you know
if you have a a box of gas for example
then if you have more gas over on one
side of the Box than over on the other
side of the Box it'll eventually
equilibrate and get to be roughly equal
densities of the gas in the box but
it'll it'll do that because molecules
from one side bounce over the other side
they bounce back the whole box the
molecules are able to travel from one
side to the other and all interact but
if you're dealing with the early
universe
uh it can be the case that there's a
part of it that just never had a chance
to interact with another part of the
universe at least if there wasn't
something sort of funky going on
well the question of whether there could
be some some mechanism for interaction
one of the popular ideas is this idea of
inflation actually that idea I think the
very first place that that well maybe it
appeared very early at least in a
footnote to a paper I wrote with a
another person back in 1979 or so
um but for various reasons we didn't
believe that the amount of inflation
would be enough to have a uh we knew
that it would have an interesting effect
on the homogeneity of the universe but
we didn't think that the effect it
requires kind of super cooling the
universe to the point where there are
things that should have happened it's
kind of like like if you have some water
and you cool it down below zero degrees
centigrade and you keep you know
wiggling the water around maybe or you
keep or you keep no actually you keep
the water really really still
you might not form ice
but as soon as there's a little nucleus
of ice that forms Kaboom the whole you
know the whole volume of water will turn
to ice but there is a an ability to
super cool things as well as to super
heat things you can have water that is
above its boiling point and until it
nucleates uh until you you get the sort
of bubble you don't start to get steam
formed so you can have the super cooling
process where you have taken something
like water cooled it below its freezing
point it doesn't start to actually
freeze until some little sort of
freezing nucleus which could be a grain
of dust could be all sorts of things uh
shows up so the question was could the
universe be super cooled
um and if it could be and there was no
in homogeneity gravitational and
homogeneity for example in the universe
you could potentially super cool it but
you have to super cool it over a huge
range of temperatures and if you did
that then the properties of the universe
would be very different
the universe would behave as if it has
Oh weird negative Mass stuff finish and
all kinds of weird stuff and the
universe would have a period of very
very rapid expansion and uh the um and
that would explain this whole question
about why different parts of the
universe can kind of see each other
because they were sort of in contact
back before this exponential expansion
and so on
this is a theory that I must say has
gotten very ornate over the years and
people have had to add all kinds of
different features and extra particles
and all sorts of things that haven't
been seen in their Slow Roll inflation
and inflatons and just a whole bunch of
of of stuff and usually when you look at
scientific theories one of the things is
you've got a certain set of things to
explain and you've got a certain set of
things you put into the theory
you win when the things the number of
things you put into the theory is really
small compared to the number of things
the theory explains
what's happened with inflation I'm
afraid is not really that it's gone the
other way it's been in order to explain
what you see you have to pour in all of
this weird things you keep on patching
things and so on it doesn't to me it
doesn't have the right vibe to be a
correct Theory
so in fact in our physics project one of
the nice things that comes out is that
there is a theory of how homogeneity
happens in the universe and it happens
because the universe was originally
infinite dimensional and that means and
you can think about the universe it's as
a big sort of graph it has a bunch of
points in space and these points they're
not actually defined by a position in
space they're just defined by how
they're connected to other points so you
form this big graph and that graph in
effect effectively defines the structure
of space so if the graph happened to
connect everything to four nearest
neighbors and each one of those to four
nearest neighbors and so on in a grid it
will be sort of an effectively
two-dimensional space
if at the beginning every node was
basically connected to every other node
that's effectively an infinite
dimensional space as you get fewer nodes
connected to a given node you get
basically lower dimensional space in in
at the beginning you can have infinite
dimensional space and at that point sort
of every every node affects every other
node and so that means that sort of
explains why one side of the universe
what's now one side of the universe was
in that infinite dimensional State
something that was infinitely close to
every other part of the universe and
that means that this fact that the
different features of the universe are
comparable in all sort of sides is very
unsurprising in that picture because the
whole universe was just connected you
know one step away from each other in in
kind of a moment in one moment of time
so to speak an effect could could move
from any part of the universe to any
other part of the universe back then but
as the dimension of the universe
decreased that became more and more
difficult to be the case to the point
where now there can be that one Photon
that was or these two photons which were
emitted from sort of different ends of
the universe and they only meet now but
they will have met their precursors
which won't have been photons yet will
have met before when the universe was
infinite dimensional and before the the
universe kind of cooled down to be uh to
be finite dimensional so but we don't
know that's what happened I strongly
think that's what happened but in terms
of the sort of basic picture of the
universe was hot and small yes that
really is pretty established published
at this point
um the the question of sort of what
happens in the very very early parts of
the Universe I would say back to one
second maybe even a microsecond we have
pretty good knowledge of what was
happening in the universe the success of
calculations of the different abundances
of different kinds of Isotopes
um are encouraging another phenomenon
that was happened in the early Universe
I worked on quite a bit many many years
ago is that why there's more matter than
antimatter in the universe so you know
just as their electrons they're also
anti-electrons positrons just as there
are protons there are anti-protons an
anti-proton has the same mass as a
proton but it has the opposite charge
opposite electric charge and that's the
general principle of antiparticles every
electric charge like thing they have is
negative for the antibarticle so for
example when two antiparticles meet they
electron a positron they will be
attracted to each other actually there's
even a weird kind of atom called
positronium in which an electron is kind
of going around a positron as opposed to
an electron
um positronium is is much bigger than
well bigger than than um
um
all right yeah that's right the um in
any case the the
um
the thing that um uh so in the very very
early Universe there should have been an
equal amount of matter and antimatter
there isn't now
back even 40 years ago we didn't know
whether there were anti-stars or
anti-galaxies it could have been the
case that you know
the Andromeda galaxy could have been
made of antimatter the nearest big
spiral galaxy to ours could have been
made of antimatter we didn't know it
could have been the case that half the
galaxies just like you know half the
galaxies rotate sort of clockwise in
some sense half anti-clockwise in some
sense it could have been the case that
they um uh uh that half the galaxies
were um uh were Mata and half were
antimatter
it seems not to be the case it seems to
be the case that matter and antimatter
um there is an excess of matter over
antimatter by about one part and 100
million so there's about one part 100
million more matter than antimatter in
the universe
at the point where things like nuclei
and then galaxies and all that kind of
thing formed why is that
well nobody knows for sure but there's a
model which again I actually worked on
back in 1979 1980 for why this happens
and it's a pretty ornate story
that is very connected to proton decay
and it is
uh the things that would make that
happen are the same as the things that
would make protons Decay and it's a
little bit embarrassing that proton
decay hasn't been observed for some of
these theories of how matter antimatter
asymmetry occurs but it's a slightly
long story of um how you get well not so
bad it's a okay so matter and antimatter
the the properties of of an
anti-particle the charges negated the
mass is the same one of the things was
discovered over the last few decades is
that antimatter falls under Gravity it
doesn't have negative Mass it has
positive Mass it falls just the same way
as natter Falls and so on so it
um it works that way
okay next fact about antimatter
is that if you have an unstable particle
and you have an anti-version of that
particle the total lifetime of the
unstable particle is the same as the
total lifetime of its antibarticle
um however
in a rather subtle effect
there can be a difference if there are
two different things that the particles
can Decay to there can be a difference
in the Decay rate
to one of those things the other thing
for the particle versus the antiparticle
an example where this is known as the k0
particle it's a particle with a mass
about half the mass of a proton it
decays in about 10 to the minus eight
seconds well actually it's a little bit
complicated because there are two
versions of it one decays in 10 to the
minus eight seconds one decays and tenth
of minus 10 seconds and it's a
complicated story how those things Decay
and one feature they have is if you were
to look at how much of the short
decaying versus the long decaying one of
the k0 exists and you just go forwards
in time from a given point you say how
much case K's are short how much K's are
long there'll be a certain amount of
each one and there'll be some
oscillations and so on and you measure
that and it's a certain form going
forwards in time weird fact if you were
to reverse time go backwards those
Wiggles work differently it's the
example of so-called time reversal
violation it's a small effect about one
part in a thousand in the decay of the
k0 Amazon
um and uh it's weird effect
it doesn't affect the full Decay rate of
the k0 but it does affect whether the
Decay the k0 decays more into two pounds
or more into three pions and that's sort
of different if you were going forward
in time that if you were going backward
in time
um that's a different effect if you're
thinking about the second law of
Thermodynamics and entropy and things is
a slightly different effect it doesn't
really engage with those kinds of
questions
um this is a different this is a
so-called well time reversal violation
also equivalent to a thing called CP
violation
oh boy getting into complicated things
here one General feature of physics is
that if you take a physical process and
you make a movie of it and it's doing
what it does as a function of time
and then you reverse the you know you
you run the movie in reverse the
question is could that reverse thing
happen equally well and the answer is
this time reversal violation phenomenon
means that there's a small effect
whereby it doesn't happen equally well
but if you not only reverse the time but
also look at antibarticles and also
invert space and everything that was
spinning one way is now spinning the
other way but sorry everything that was
going one way
um is sort of going the other way spin
Works differently the um uh
and you do simultaneously charge
conjugation that is particles to
antiparticles parity inversion that's
invert space and time reversal that's
reverse the direction of time if you do
three or three of those things
simultaneously that's what's called an
in particle physics for example CPT
transformation charge configuration
parity time reversal transformation
according to current theories of quantum
field Theory every process is unchanged
by CPT transformation so time reversal
on its own
you can have a something which looks
different for time reversal and then it
will also look different for CP
Transformations but if you combine CP
and T then it will always look the same
footnote to this nobody knows whether
gravity satisfies CPT invariance and it
probably doesn't
um but that's that's a that's a that's a
footnote to this whole story but the
question whether it does or doesn't is
actually pretty subtle because of the
way that one even sets up the notion of
what at what time is in in gravitational
fields and so on in any case the um uh
let's see what I was explaining was how
one gets this effect of um uh uh how one
gets Mata a Mata antimatter asymmetry
and basically the answer that um we came
up with many years ago is that there
have to be these particles that are a
very massive compared to protons we've
never seen them we haven't been able to
produce them in particle accelerators
yet and those particles decay
in a way that violates CP
um and some of the Decay modes some of
the things they Decay into the the
amount of of particles versus
antiparticles of some part of what they
Decay into is different that interacting
with the way the universe expands leads
to the small asymmetry matter of
antimatter subtle effect subtle effect
important for us because that's why
we're here if it was the case that
matter and antimatter were an exactly
equal quantities in the universe
probably all the matter and antimatter
would have annihilated away and we just
get left with a bunch of photons and
electrons and positrons and we wouldn't
have had heavier things in the atoms
that we're used to and all those kinds
of things it's not completely certain
that's the case it could be true that
you could have sort of a region of the
universe that was matter and it was an
original of the universe that was
antimatter and right at the boundary
between them there could be Annihilation
happening and that could produce
radiation pressure that holds the other
parts apart it's not completely clear
whether that would work but it doesn't
happen in our universe as far as we can
tell oh
all right I'm just maybe one more thing
and then I probably to um I should
wrap up soon let's see
uh Brady is asking would you make of the
very early galaxies seen by the JWT that
base telescope which seemed to
too large to exist so early
yeah I mean I think there was a claim
that there were some galaxies that
existed only millions of years after the
beginning of the universe and I think
that claim didn't survive
um I think that will be a bit a bit
early I mean people
kind of believed that there was a period
when there wasn't a lot of light being
produced in the universe because the the
original heat of the Big Bang had kind
of cooled down to the point where it
wasn't generating uh visible light
and yet there have been no gravitational
clumping that led to things like stars
which could start to have Fusion
reactions which would lead to visible
light so there was a sort of period
where people have assumed that there's
kind of a Dark Age where where there
isn't visible light produced in the
history of the early history of the
universe
that you know quite where the first
galaxies will show up is not known yet
um but there were some claims of very
early galaxies it's kind of tricky to
know you know how do you know where when
a Galaxy was originated you know that
because galaxies because of the
expansion of the universe
galaxies that were originated early
are
effectively their effective looked at by
us
sort of this late relative to when they
existed in the history of the universe
the relative speed of us relative to
that Galaxy is very close to the speed
of light and we are effectively seeing
the a very red-shifted a very um uh kind
of like the way that you you know when
you when a siren goes past you and you
hear it lower when it's going away from
you that same effect happens with
frequency of light uh when things are
going away from you close to the speed
of light and that's what that's what
happens for distant galaxies you kind of
know how far away it is by knowing
things about the expansion rate of the
universe and how low the frequency of
the light has got
so that's sort of the big measure is the
so-called redshift it's usually called Z
and uh you know Z of five well people
have seen galaxies out there but you
know Z of uh what is it sea of
what is it
three thousand is that right I think
that's what it is relative to
recombination was it 2500 I've forgotten
maybe it's 2500
um so you know Galaxy's been known for a
while out to about zf5 there are things
at least very galaxies that produce very
intense
um uh radiation but um you know getting
to the very beginning to the point of
recombination 100 000 years off the
beginning of the universe that would be
much much further out and uh there's a
question of sort of how far out can you
observe
um
let's see
uh
I say this question here is the possible
expansion of space due to Dark Energy
could eventually be fast enough that
even atoms of nuclei come apart
uh
yes
I mean in
there are certainly places where
the structure of space-time is so wild
that every material object has pulled
apart
that happens near a space-time
singularity
that exists at the center of a black
hole for example
it's kind of a it's very tricky business
to get in naked Singularity a place
where there's a singularity in
space-time but it isn't surrounded by an
event horizon that has the property that
everything that falls into that
eventualizing can never signal out but
by you know kind of subtle way it's
possible to get
well
sort of a temporary sort of roughly
place where there is a singularity in
space-time what does that mean it means
that uh and that you can observe there's
a singularity at the center of black
hole but it's hidden behind it Event
Horizon
what happens at that Singularity one
thing that happens is the curvature of
space becomes infinite and so what does
curvature space mean well it think about
if you have two parallel lines and
they're just they're going along they're
next to each other they stay parallel
they never meet but if you draw those
parallel lines on a curved surface those
parallel lines will eventually cross and
the fact that those parallel lines sort
of approach each other is the same
effect according to general relativity
is the same effect as the deflection of
a particle's motion by gravity
so in other words when there is a the
the deflection by gravity is the same
phenomenon as space not being flat as
space being curved and so when one says
well the curvature of space is getting
very very big it's equivalent to saying
there's a really big amount of gravity
there and so what happens at a
space-time Singularity is that the
culture of space becomes infinite as
effectively an infinite amount of
gravity there and that means that any
material object
and including an atom it's pieces will
be essentially torn apart because the
structure of space in which they exist
is being torn apart so yes it is true
that you can get from a gravitational
effect from gravitational singularity
you can tear apart you you kind of the
the the it's you know you might say well
there's a there's a proton here there's
an electron here but no well actually
where's here well here is getting torn
apart because the very structure of
space is getting torn apart and that's
actually a clearer thing to see in our
models because you actually see the
structure of the of the graph that
represents the structure of space which
is normally kind of bubbling around and
rearranging itself and so on you can
actually get pieces of that graph become
disconnected and that's the sort of
extreme version of how you can have
something where sort of Parts a
different so if one if the electron is
on one side of that disconnection the
proton is on the other side then they
are very much torn part
so uh
oh let's see
um
there's a question here how's the
temperature of the cosmic microwave
background measured
um actually several friends of mine have
been involved in doing those
measurements
um
the okay so the frequencies of light
frequencies of electromagnetic radiation
that corresponds to the cosmic microbe
background
are okay first point is
if you heat something up it'll
eventually glow red hot
then it'll glow white Hearts then it'll
glow blue hearts
what's happening there is there's a
relationship between the temperature and
the typical frequency of photons which
determines their color produced by a um
uh produced by heating something up
so if you heat something up really
really hot it'll produce X-rays and all
kinds of crazy electromagnetic radiation
if you heat something up just a tiny
tiny bit it'll produce infrared then
it'll produce microwaves and it'll
produce other longer frequency radio
waves and so on well the cosmic
microwave background so for example an
incandescent bulb like the sun it's it's
heated up to about 6000 degrees at 6000
degrees you get roughly white light you
get roughly equal amounts of the
different colors of light
so the cosmic record background it's
effectively heated up to around 2.7
degrees Kelvin 2.7 kelvins
um uh 2.7 degrees above absolute zero
and that's so that's so it produces a
certain frequency of electromagnetic
radiation that is in the microwave range
it's it's radio frequency radiation the
cosmic micro background was discovered
around 1964 if I remember correctly when
people at Bell Labs were trying to set
up a kind of microwave Communications
with satellites and so they had um a uh
you know they had this whole assembly
and they were you know they were trying
to transmit signals to satellites they
were very early satellites mostly I
think just these mylar balloons that
would reflect radio waves and they
noticed that
they noticed
excuse me
um
they noticed that uh try as they might
they couldn't
get zero noise in the microwave signal
they would always get some Relic some
temperature some effective temperature
of random microwaves that were entering
their devices and actually they rather
quickly figured out that that might be
the Relic radiation from a big bang so
that was how it was discovered in
today's world the um there are some
exotic ways that the temperatures get
measured to do it accurately to within a
thousandth of a degree uh there's a
detector at the south pole that is uh
that does that
um it's important that you don't have a
lot of temperature around that
um uh can sort of produce
you're measuring it by measuring radio
radio waves but you need your detector
to be very cold and you need everything
to be very cold it's good to be at the
South Pole if you're doing that
um even better is to be in space a
satellite called the Planck satellite
that is at the LaGrange point in the
Earth Moon Sun system so that's the
place where where it's um see which
LaGrange point is that I think it's at
the one that has uh kind of uh the um
the one that's that's uh uh
away from the earth in an equilateral
triangle with with the sun
um and uh it's it's sensitively capable
of measuring the um uh the cosmic
microwave background
um and actually a friend of mine built
some of the equipment for that and it's
one of these things where if you have
your equipment at the LaGrange point in
the Earth Moon Sun System unless it
becomes a tourist attraction it's just
hanging out there for billions of years
and so you know if you kind of sign your
your uh your little piece of apparatus
there it's kind of your signal your
signature is out there for billions of
years which is kind of fun
um
all right I think
I think I probably have to wrap up here
although there are a bunch of
interesting questions about um
yeah I don't think I can address these
right now
um
well all right we had a cosmology and
well you had a chemistry and cosmology
day today I never know what's going to
come up here
um it's always uh always fun for me and
I hope you all find it interesting
um we've talked about very different
kinds of things and different in
different uh different times here I've
kind of had the idea that I might try
and um uh make these a little bit more
uh a definite one topic uh kinds of
things uh because it's uh easier if
people want to find these sometime in
the future
um the to find stuff about a particular
topic might be easier than but we'll see
um well thanks thanks for joining me and
uh see you again another time
bye for now